welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
actor Jonathan Majors recently revealed
that King the Conqueror is in fact a
Nexus being in the MCU you know like on
the same level of the freaking
Illuminati eliminating chaos Queen the
Scarlet Witch like how is that possible
and what does it mean to be a Nexus
being in the MCU these days and why is
Kang one of them and how many Nexus
beings do we know of so far let's get
into all these questions together my
nerd babies because this is very
interesting stuff here and hey this
video is brought to you by Squarespace
more on them later but there's nothing
more interesting than this shirt that
I'm wearing right now I freaking love
these quantumania designs that we have
at nerdriot.shop they're so freaking
cool especially the one that I designed
that has Kang as the Vitruvian man well
I didn't design it because I can't draw
for we have an amazing artist that
um took my idea and made it to life and
they put it on a shirt for you guys to
wear so check that out and um you can
wear it and be like oh my God the
Haitian guy made this
um co-made right so in a recent press
conference King the Conqueror actor
Jonathan Majors The Man your partner
secretly wants to be with said that Kang
is a time traveling super villain who is
also a Nexus being which leads to the
idea of variance this means that King
the Conqueror is now confirmed as the
second Nexus being on the MCU map much
like he is in the comics but what does
it mean to be a Nexus being like the
Scarlet Witch well basically according
to the Watcher in what if issue number
35 a Nexus being in the Marvel Comics is
someone with an immense amount of power
to affect not just their own universe
but multiple universes timelines within
the overall Multiverse essentially
people who can alter the course of the
future of the health of multiple
realities and the reason why Kang is a
Nexus being is because he and the vast
multitudes of his conquering variants
have the immense power necessary to
affect the Multiverse on a massive scale
not just with his own native Universe
you know as evidenced by he who remains
installing an entire freaking time
variance authority to erase entire
universes on the right regular and this
is why the Scarlet Witch is regarded as
a Nexus being as well because as we
learned from Multiverse of Madness by
reading the dark hold and gaining the
knowledge of the multiverse's existence
and the ability to dreamwalk through
that Multiverse Wanda officially became
a Nexus being herself simply by Blue
skadooing into various monsters and
variants of herself across the
Multiverse for her own ends and thus
greatly affecting the fates of those
universes and this much is alluded to in
that one division commercial for the
Nexus pill from episode 7. specifically
when the voice over lady notes that
taking Nexus can anchor you to your
reality or any reality of your choosing
a unique antidepressant that works to
Anchor you back to your reality
or the reality of your choice with that
red pill symbolizing Wanda's chaos magic
and its ability to allow her to
dreamwalk and anchor herself to any
reality that she desires I mean just
think about how the Scarlet Witch Left
4838 Wanda to Bear the blame for the
assassinations of the leaders of the
Inhumans the X-Men and the Fantastic
Four when that was actually 616 Wanda
like if anybody in a3a tried to take E38
Wanda away from her children could be
potentially catastrophic for the
Multiverse or at the very least for that
Universe because you know if a381 is
anything like 616 Wanda she's not gonna
let anyone take her away from her kids
like it's not gonna happen like either I
feel so bad A3 Wanda was just chilling
and then she just had a real life ruined
by what like a 616 what's up and this
brings us to our next Nexus being in the
MCU and a pretty big one according to
the Illuminati Dr Strange and all of his
variants because according to Reed
Richards and the rest of his secret
science Soldier friends Dr Strange
variants across the Multiverse have
routinely proven to be a threat to the
health of multiple realities if not ever
a reality in the Multiverse in the prime
example being a 3A Doctor Strange
triggering the upcoming MCU Multiverse
incursions by dream walking into one of
his variants and causing the early
annihilation of that variance Universe
with the dark hole so considering that
a3a doctor strange is going to be the
reason why Earth 616 is going to have to
fight other heroes from other universes
in secret Wars A3 Doctor Strange should
definitely meet this criteria of a Nexus
being who can change the fate of the
Multiverse and look guys we're going to
get back to the video in just one second
but I gotta tell you guys about
Squarespace not only are they making it
possible for me to do this video but
they could be making it possible for you
huge but honestly whatever you want to
do online that's because Squarespace
makes it easy to make an awesome website
that lets you engage with your audience
and sell anything that you need your
products content you create and even
your time Squarespace is the all-in-one
platform for building your brand and
growing your business online if you're
into making videos Squarespace can help
you create Pro level videos effortlessly
the Squarespace video studio app will
help you make and share engaging videos
to tell your story grow your audience in
Drive sales but hey maybe videos aren't
your thing because you're more of a
social media buff no problem you can
display posts from any profile that you
want on your website and automatically
push website content to your favorite
social media channels so your followers
can share it too no matter what you're
doing Squarespace analytic tools will
help you learn where your traffic and
sales are coming from so you can improve
your website and build a marketing
strategy based either on your top
keywords or most popular products and
content head to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com new
rockstars to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain when we
think Squarespace once again for
sponsoring this video but also we can't
forget that other doctor strange variant
strange Supreme whose abuse of power
also led to the early termination of his
Reality by the end of his episode of
what if well almost but not entirely
because as we saw from the end of what
if season one strange Supreme now lives
in what remains of his ruined reality as
he keeps watch over two other Nexus
beings to be killmonger infinity or Zola
infinity and I say Nexus beings to be
because when we last left them
killmonger and Zola were both fighting
for that power to affect the Multiverse
in their prison so theoretically whoever
were to win that tug of war would be a
Nexus beat but since straight Supreme is
their new Warden he is technically in
possession of that power something tells
me he's going to take it for himself in
what if season two but needless to say
Ultron Infinity achieved Nexus Hood when
he assembled the Infinity Stones to
start annihilating life across every
reality so he is our next MCU Nexus B
Ultron Infinity from what if but we also
can't forget about the MCU first Nexus
being dormammu a being with an
insatiable appetite to consume entire
universes in the Multiverse and a being
but I highly suspect to be the very
variants that a3a to Doctor Strange
corrupted with the dark hold and
destroyed his reality creating the dark
dimension like I literally think that
duramu is a doctor strange variant
because dormammu is played by Benedict
Cumberbatch and Doctor Strange one so
there is a chance that dermamu is
secretly that poor a38 Doctor Strange
victim that Clea needs Doctor Strange to
heal because we see them heading towards
the dark dimension at the end of
Multiverse Madness but there's also the
mcu's newest and youngest Nexus being on
the Block America Chavez a young lady
with the power to punch her away across
realities and steal as many pizza balls
as she wants and you know also help
people from time to time but only when
she learns how to control her powers and
of course the Watcher from what if is
another big one as his actions of
intervention save the entire Multiverse
as a whole from Ultron Infinity You know
despite his vow of non-interference but
you know he always breaks that vow
constantly in the comics he's like he
just he just never really follows that
and finally the season finale of
She-Hulk proved that the greatest Nexus
being of all is in fact the Kevin AI
robot at Marvel Studios who is capable
of editing timelines and multiverses at
will and has even the knowledge of the
X-Men in his Noggin a gracious God of
Gears who gifted a gamma gal a handsome
devil with his omnipotent Powers which
is what you're supposed to do when you
have the powers of a God make sure that
all the ladies in the world look at the
booty calls that they need because who
runs the world girls a prophetess told
me that in a dream but yeah those are
all the Nexus beings in the MCU so far
that I can list according to Marvel's
definition of what a Nexus being is a
and every variant of him has the
potential to massively alter the fates
of every single Universe in existence
like Wanda almost could have done in
Multiverse of Madness but is there
anybody else in the MCU that you guys
can think of that could be a Nexus being
according to this definition let us know
in the comments below but thank you guys
so much for watching this video you can
follow me at Master retainment on
Twitter if you guys want to see me tweet
some weird really fun theories I've
been tweeting a lot of Zelda theories
lately which is kind of weird but mostly
between MCU theories but most
importantly you can follow new rockstars
wherever we are on the social medias and
of course do not forget to hit up
nerdriot.shop so you can buy all of our
cool awesome nerd stuff over there
including these awesome Quantum Mania
shirts they're so freaking cool make
sure you guys buy one of these shirts
because it's a great way to support the
channel it really helps us out and you
look fly doing so but again I love you
guys so much and I'll see you guys next
time goodbye
all right
[Music]